[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Anne gellineck guten Abend in
den letzten Nächten fliegt die russische
Armee wieder vermehrt Angriffe mit
Raketen und Drohnen auf Kiev das dabei
wohl keine Menschen getötet wurden ist
ein Erfolg der ukrainischen
Luftverteidigung die sich wesentlich auf
westliche Systeme stützt Waffen denen
bald die Munition ausgehen könnte auch
weil das amerikanische Parlament die
Militärhilfe für die Ukraine weiter
blockiert genau deshalb hat US-Präsident
Joe Biden volodimir selenski nach
Washington eingeladen wohl in der
Hoffnung dass der redeewandte Ukrainer
die skeptischen Republikaner überzeugen
könne Claudia Bates
berichtet Vorfahrt beim sten Verbündeten
die Stimmung ist gedrückt selenski
verschwindet unauffällig im Weißen Haus
wo er zumindest mit jemandem spricht der
absolut hinter ihm
steht der Kongress muss jetzt die
beantragten Hilfen für die Ukraine
verabschieden noch vor den
Weihnachtsferien sonst geben Sie Putin
das größte Weihnachtsgeschenk
überhaupt die Menschen brauchen
Zuversicht dass die Freiheit sicher ist
und Star genug um zu
gewinnen zuvor im Kongress ein anderes
Bild hier muss er um weitere Milliarden
kämpfen sind Sie optimistisch dass sie
die Abgeordneten überzeugen können aber
zelenski hat wenig Grund für Optimismus
zwar ist eine Mehrheit der Abgeordneten
dafür der Ukraine zu helfen sie ist aber
ins Räderwerk des politischen Betriebs
geraten America first gilt für die
Republikaner konservativer
Isolationismus deshalb haben sie die
Hilfen für die Ukraine an verschärfte
Regeln in der Migrationspolitik
geknüpft wir haben eine Verantwortung
für die USA ich kann doch nicht in
meinen Staat gehen und sagen ich kümmere
mich um andere Länder aber nicht um mein
eigenes vor einem Jahr Applaus für den
Helden selenski im Parlament doch die
Stimmung hat sich geändert heute
Einzeltreffen hinter verschlossenen
Türen welche ein Kontrast diesmal muss
er bitten muss appellieren und selbst
das wird kaum zünden die Ukraine gerade
nur Spielball im innenpolitischen Streit
ist dabei ist allen klar was auf dem
Spiel
steht wenn selenski die Hilfe bekommt
die er braucht wird er gewinnen er hat
auch klar gemacht dass wenn wir
verlieren dann gewinnt Putin und das
wäre sehr gefährlich für die
USA aber auch die Demokraten bewegen
sich bislang kaum Biden hatte eine
humanere Flüchtlingspolitik versprochen
nun hat er sich kompromissbereit erklärt
will aber auch seine Stamm wler nicht
verprellen um ehrlich zu sein genau das
sollte er tun denn seine eigene Bilanz
bei der Migration ist dürftig und eine
politische Belastung und diese Politik
kann man später auch wieder ändern aber
wenn die Ukraine geschlagen wird das ist
unumkehrbar deshalb sollte beiden
erkennen er muss jetzt einen Deal
machen die Zeit wird knapp Ende der
Woche wollen die Abgeordneten in die
Weihnachtsferien kaum einer hier will
Putin gewinnen lassen die Verhandlungen
werden weiter gehen aber offenbar drängt
um 11 Uhr die Zeit noch nicht
genug vielleicht war es von Anfang an
eine Schnapsidee die
Weltklimakonferenz in einem Ölstaat
stattfinden zu lassen und ausgerechnet
dort in den Vereinigten Arabischen
Emiraten den endgültigen Ausstieg aus
fossilen Energien wie Gas Öl und Kohle
verhandeln zu wollen und da kann es
eigentlich nicht verwundern dass der
Tagungspräsident und Ölmanager
zunächst eine Abschlusserklärung
vorlegte die den Ausstieg gar nicht
erwähnte Saudi-Arabien Russland und
China freuten sich die Europäer sind
empört und so geht die Klimakonferenz
die eigentlich heute Vormittag zu Ende
sein sollte in die nächste Nachtschicht
unser Reporter Mark Hugo
auch es gibt auch die kleinen guten
Nachrichten auf der
Weltklimakonferenz die kaffeestände
bleiben offen auch die Nacht durch viele
würden die Dauer Verhandlungen sonst
vielleicht nicht schaffen fast schon
traditionell geht die Kop zum Endspurt
in die Verlängerung es gilt sich
vielleicht doch noch auf einen
weltweiten Ausstieg aus Kohle Gas und Öl
zu einigen na das muss man sich dann
schon vorstellen dass es tatsächlich
sehr ins Detail geht dass wirklich
Textvorschläge kommen dass man um
einzelne Wörter ringt von daher geht's
jetzt darum ein Gesamtpaket zu
verhandeln damit viele Länder zustimmen
können aber wie immer es ist nichts
entschieden bevor nicht alles
entschieden ist vor allem Saudi-Arabien
blockiert das Land verdient Milliarden
mit Öl und Gas sitzt auf gewaltigen
Reserven ein Ausstieg für die Saudis
nicht
vorstellbar ja wir sehen hier dass der
fossilen Industrie und einigen fossilen
Staaten es scheinbar komplett egal sind
ist was draußen in der Welt eigentlich
passiert und wie sehr fossile Emissionen
schon heute überall Leben nehmen und
Realitäten rauben und Zukünfte rauben
und was für ein unfassbare
Ungerechtigkeit dahinter steht am frühen
morgen heißt es will die
kpräsidentschaft einen neuen zweiten
Entwurf für eine Abschlusserklärung
vorlegen was drin stehen soll machen
noch einmal diese Aktivisten klar
weltweit konsequent raus aus den
fossilen Sowi das auch von weit mehr als
100 Ländern gefordert wird gestern in
einem ersten Entwurf war davon noch
nichts zu lesen gewesen stattdessen ein
reines wünscht dir was auf freiwilliger
Basis die Enttäuschung war
groß alle Staaten mit der Ausnahme von
Saudiarabien haben haben gesagt das ist
nicht der Text über den wir so
verhandeln können den wir so akzeptieren
können und von dem herer muss es
eigentlich jetzt einen deutlich besseren
Text geben der vorgelegt wird noch lässt
der aber auf sich warten dabei hängt
vieles davon ab wird die Cop 28 am Ende
scheitern oder gibt es doch noch den
Durchbruch auf den viele hoffen kaffee
soll ja kleine Wunder
vollbringen unser klimareporter Andreas
Stamm beobachtet für uns das Ringen um
den Klimaschutz Andreas worauf könnte es
denn hinauslaufen bei der Suche nach
einem
Kompromiss ja ich denke das ist eben die
Quadratur des Kreises und es kann im
Moment eigentlich niemand richtig sagen
da wird auch wie im Beitrag angedeutet
Kaffee nur schwer helfen denn die
Positionen sind einfach so gegensätzlich
da hat man diese Koalition aus wohl mehr
als 100 Staaten darunter die EU
Deutschland die sagen also mit einem
wachswe wachsweichen Kompromiss lassen
wir uns hier nicht abspeisen es muss
schon ein klares Zeichen in Richtung
Ausstieg aus den fossilen Energieträgern
geben und dann die erdölfördernden
Staaten da ist nicht nur Saudi-Arabien
sondern auch andere die klar machen das
ist der Grund für unseren Wohlstand und
Reichtum und wir haben im Moment noch
keine Alternative dafür das lassen wir
uns nicht nehmen egal was ihr hier
bestimmen wollt und dann gibt's auch
noch den globalen Süden die durchaus
sagen das sind die Schwellenländer die
ärmeren Länder die sagen ja wir sind
dabei aber wie sollen wir das Bezahlen
ihr im reichen Norden habt ja selbst
problememe bei der Umsetzung dieser
transform tion ja und dann steht da noch
dieser koppräsident ein absolutes Rätsel
jeder fragt sich was macht er hier hat
er den Westen oder die die aussteigen
wollen in eine Falle gelockt hat sich
sozusagen schön Honig um den Bart
geschmiert und am Ende jetzt gezeigt
dass er ein Wolfs ein Wolf im Schafspelz
ist oder ist eine geniale Taktik indem
er ja jetzt so viel Druck erzeugt hat
mit diesem Text auf Saudi-Arabien auf
andere dass die einknicken müssen und
man doch noch zu einem wie er sagt
historischen Ergebnis kommen kann also
es ist so viel drin hier in diesem im
Spiel und es wird jetzt verhandelt durch
die Nacht ich glaube es gibt keine freie
Minute für die Verhandler und dann soll
morgen früh 6 Uhr Ortszeit vielleicht
etwas auf dem Tisch liegen was dann dann
was das dann ist es ist so schwer
abzusehen vielleicht muss man eben
versuchen den Ländern die die
Transformation länger dafür länger
brauchen mehr Zeit zu geben dass man den
Ölländern in ja einfach aufzeigt wie sie
die Transformation schaffen können
entweder mit grünem Wasserstoff Solar
windnd da gibt es Möglichkeiten aber die
sind eben bislang noch nicht überzeugt
und ob diese Überzeugungsarbeit wirklich
hier gelingt da zweifeln viele dran eine
lange Nacht und vielleicht sogar noch
ein langer Tag Andreas Stamm war das
live aus Dubai vielen Dank
dorthin es klingt wie ein ziemlich
abstruses Planspiel eine Gruppe
sogenannter Reichsbürger rund um den
Frankfurter Geschäftsmann Heinrich der
13 Prinz Reus plant die Machtübernahme
in Deutschland Prinz Reus sah sich als
Oberhaupt eines neuen
Staatsgebildes Staatsgebildes eine
Gruppe rund um ehemalige Soldaten und
Polizisten war dabei militante
bürgerwererden aufzubauen man könnte das
alles für Spinnerei halten wenn die
Gruppe nicht schwer bewaffnet und straff
organisiert gewesen wäre so fielen der
Polizei bei ihrer rtiia vor einem Jahr
ganze Personallisten in die Hände
außerdem hatten sich die Mitglieder bei
Todesstrafe zur Geheimhaltung
verpflichtet die Bundesanwaltschaft hat
heute Klage erhoben Jan Henrich mit den
Details für die Bundesanwaltschaft steht
fest es war mehr als die bloße Fantasie
vom statsstreich sie hätten konkrete
Vorbereitungen getroffen Umsturzpläne so
der Vorwurf gegen die Gruppe bereits vor
einem Jahr die Festnahmen unter anderem
Heinrich der 13 Prinz Reus nach
Auswertung der Beweismittel nun die
Anklagen gegen 27 mutmaßliche Beteiligte
diesen werfen wir insbesondere vor eder
oder Unterstützer in einem Fall einer
terroristischen Vereinigung gewesen zu
sein wir haben Sie zudem wegen der
Vorbereitung eines hofverräterischen
Unternehmens angeklagt die
Ermittlungsergebnisse machen das Ausmaß
deutlich ein ganzes Waffenarsenal soll
die Gruppe angeholuft haben darunter
rund 380 Schusswaffen schusssichere
Westen
Nachtsichtgeräte ein Ziel laut Ermittler
der Bundestag eine bewaffnete Gruppe
sollte dort gewaltsam eindringen
Abgeordnete und Regierungsmitglied
festnehmen der geplante Machtwechsel
sollte unterstützt werden durch ein
deutschlandweites System von sogenannten
heimatschutzkompanien insgesamt sollten
286 dieser militärischen verbinde Bände
Deutschland weit aufgebaut werden der
Umfang der juristischen Aufarbeitung
enorm gleich drei Oberlandesgerichte
sollen sich mit dem Komplex beschäftigen
die Prozesse sollen aufgeteilt werden
auf die Standorte Frankfurt Stuttgart
und München die Anzahl der Beschuldigten
und auch noch weitere Ermittlungen in
dem Komplex Aussicht von
Strafrechtsexperten ist das eine neue
Dimension im NSU Komplex hatten es ja
eher mit einer Handvoll von beschulden
zu tun bei der RF waren be den stamen
Prozessen zwei Handvoll von
Beschuldigten es gibt natürlich
Verfahren bei den auch mehr Beschuldigte
angeklagt werden aber hier haben es doch
mit einer außergewöhnlichen Anzahl zu
tun die auch für die Gefährlichkeit
dieser Tätergruppe spricht die Ideologie
hinter der mutmaßlich terroristischen
Vereinigung verworren von einem
Konglomerat aus unterschiedlichen
örungsmüten der reichsbürgerszene
sprechen die Ermittler dennoch sollen
die Pläne alles andere als abstrakt
gewesen sein der General Bundesanwalt
hebt zurecht hervor dass die abstrosität
des Weltbildes was im Hintergrund steht
in nicht gegen die Gefährlichkeit dieser
Tätergruppierung spricht und schon gar
nicht die Strafbarkeit ausschließt im
Gegenteil auch gerade Personen die einem
abstusen Weltbild Folgen können
natürlich schwerwiegende und auch
gefährliche Straftaten beginnen die
Aufarbeitung wird Zeit in Anspruch
nehmen allein bis zu einem möglich
Prozess auftagt kann es noch Monate
dauern und wir machen hier weiter mit
den Nachrichten und Heinz Wolf und dem
immer noch klaffenden Loch im Haushalt
ja es wird weiter um die fehlenden
Milliarden gerungen noch ist keine
Einigung verkündet bei den Beratungen
von Kanzler Scholz Finanzminister
Lindner und Vizekanzler habbeck Bewegung
gab es heute aber insoweit als die
Fraktionsvorsitzenden zeitweise zu den
Gesprächen hinzugezogen wurden
unterschiedliche Positionen gibt es etwa
dazu ob die Schuldenbremse nächsten Jahr
erneut ausgesetzt werden
soll die UN Vollversammlung ist am Abend
wegen der narostkrise zu einer
Sondersitzung zusammengekommen es soll
dabei über die humanitäre Lage im
Gazastreifen beraten werden in einem
unter anderem von Ägypten eingebrachten
Resolutionsentwurf wird eine sofortige
humanitäre Waffenruhe gefordert
Resolutionen der Vollversammlung sind
nicht
bindend mit der UN Friedensmission
minusma endet nach gut 10 Jahren auch
der Bundeswehreinsatz in Mali heute
haben die letzten deutschen Soldaten mit
zwei Transportflugzeugen das Feldlager
nah der Stadt Gao verlassen es ist nicht
gelungen Mali zu stabilisieren und den
Vormarsch islamistischer Gruppen zu
stoppen im Juni verlangte Malis an die
Macht geputschte militärrunter dass alle
UN-Soldaten das Land verlassen und
wandte sich politisch Russland
zu Polens neu Regierungschef Donald Tusk
hat vor wenigen Minuten im Parlament
eine Vertrauensabstimmung
erwartungsgemäß mit der Mehrheit seines
Dreier Bündnisses bestanden in einer
Regierungserklärung hatte Tusk zuvor
eine gute Zusammenarbeit mit der EU
angekündigt und sich klar für eine
weitere Unterstützung der Ukraine
ausgesprochen am Nachmittag kam es zu
einem eklar im Parlament ein
rechtsextremer Abgeordneter löschte die
Lichter auf einem hanuka Leuchter mit
einem Feuerlöscher es gab tumultartige
Szenen das parlamentspräsidium Schloss
den Abgeordneten von von der Sitzung aus
und kündigte Strafanzeige an trusk
nannte die Tat eine
Schande auch das britische Unterhaus hat
am Abend getagt und ein stark
umstrittenes migrationsabkommen
gebilligt das Abkommen sieht vor illegal
eingereiste Asylbewerber ungeachtet
ihrer Herkunft nach Ruanda abzuschieben
zudem sollen Teile der Menschenrechte
nicht anwendbar sein auf Abschiebungen
um den Rechtsweg für Migranten
einzuschränken premier sunak nannte
seinen Gesetzentwurf selbst das härteste
migrationsgesetz das es je gab die
Abstimmung galt als unsicher weil
Hardliner der konservativen Partei das
Gesetz zuvor als unzureichend abgelehnt
hatten im November hatte der Oberste
Gerichtshof eine erste Version des
Abkommens
gekippt der grüne Politiker jürgen trtin
hat angekündigt sein Bundestagsmandat
zum neuen Jahr niederzulegen er habe das
der Fraktion heute mit teilt gab trtin
bekannt er prägte über Jahrzehnte den
Kurs der Grünen maßgeblich mit trtin war
1998 zum ersten Mal in den Bundestag
eingezogen bis 2005 war er in der
rotgrüne Koalition dann
Bundesumweltminister als Sarah
Wagenknecht heute vor die Presse trat
konnte man ziemlich genau beobachten was
der Unterschied zwischen einem Mitglied
einer Fraktion ist und einer
fraktionslosen Abgeordneten als letztere
also als Fraktionslose darf sie keine
Sitzungsräume mehr beanspruchen und
schon gar nicht die Fraktionsebene im
Bundestag sondern musste die
Journalisten in die Eingangshalle eines
bundestagsgebäudes einladen die wie
immer kamen um die letzten Heutungen der
Linkspartei weiterzu verfolgen aus einer
Fraktion werden nun also zwei Gruppen
die sich in herzlicher Abneigung zugetan
sind Dorte Ferber berichtet aus
Berlin es gibt noch kein Programm und
noch keine Partei nur einen Verein mit
ihrem Namen und viel Aufmerksamkeit für
Sarah Wagenknecht die die Linke
verlassen hat und jetzt mit neun
weiteren Abgeordneten eine sogenannte
parlamentarische Gruppe werden will wir
hoffen ja auch auf die Fairnis der
anderen Fraktionen weil es natürlich so
ist dass wir als Gruppe ganz andere
Möglichkeiten haben politisch zu
arbeiten auch wieder im Parlament
präsent zu sein wagenknechts Abgang
führte zur Auflösung der Fraktion DIE
LINKE nun soll es bald zwei Gruppen
geben 28 Abgeordnete bleiben die Linke
weiter mit Dietmar barch an der Spitze
daneben gibt es dann die Zeh vom Bündnis
Sarah
Wagenknecht wagenknechtsbüro bleibt
erstmal weiter im Bundestag neben dem
von Dietmar Barsch samt Verbindungstür
die wird wohl nicht mehr geöffnet aus
dem einztigen Team an der
Fraktionsspitze sind längst politische
Gegner
geworden
im Moment ist es ja so dass Sara Wagen
nicht doch vergleichsweise selten da ist
wir haben uns schon immer gesehen haben
uns immer begrüßt und das wird doch
weiterhin so sein das Ziel jetzt zwei
Gruppen darüber muss der Bundestag
entscheiden welche Rechte bekommen Sie
wie viel Geld wo sollen sie sitzen
parlamentarische Praxis damit gibt es
immerhin Bündnis 90 die Grünen bildeten
in den 90er Jahren schon mal eine Gruppe
und auch die PDS sie bekamen
Mitgliedschaft in Ausschüssen und sogar
ein Telefon für den
gruppenvorsitzenden wenn man sagt was
sind denn die rechte die wir jetzt der
Gruppe die linke oder auch der Gruppe
Sarah Wagenknecht zurechnen wollen und
da wird man dann halt gucken okay was
hat man in der Vergangenheit gemacht
unter anderem was hat man 90 und 94 auch
gemacht noch ist vieles unklar das gilt
besonders für das Bündnis Sara
Wagenknecht im Januar soll die Partei
gegründet werden Spenden werden schon
jetzt gesammelt auch aus dem im
Ausland jetzt uns hier irgendwie zu
unterstellen wir würden hier aus dunklen
Kanälen finanziert also die Wahrheit ist
schlicht das sind meistens deutsche die
im Ausland leben öfter reden im
Parlament will Wagenknecht jetzt sie
steht für ihre künftige Partei und ihre
ehemalige ärgert sich drüber sind zwar
in keinem Landtag und in kaum einer
Kommune vertreten aber jetzt eben den
Bundestag mit zehn Abgeordneten aber ich
kann das nicht ändern das sind
Abgeordnete die auf den Listen der leen
gewählt worden sind nun wird es wohl
zwei Gruppen geben und zwei
konkurrierende Parteien die
Verbindungstür zwischen den Büros dürfte
weiter geschlossen
bleiben jedes Jahr im Dezember zeichnet
das Europaparlament mit dem
sacharovpreis Menschen aus die sich in
besonderer Weise um Meinungsfreiheit und
Menschenrechte verdient gemacht haben
und fast immer bleibt der Stuhl der
ausgezeichneten leer auch dieses Mal die
Preisträgerin Gina Massa Amini die junge
kurdische Iranerin die wegen eines
nachlässig getragenen Kopftuchs von der
Sittenpolizei verhaftet und geschlagen
wurde drei Tage später war sie tot das
mullerreime hat die darauffolgende
Protestbewegung in Iran brutal bekämpft
und verweigert auch jetzt den Eltern von
Massa Amini die Ausreise aus Iran um die
Ehrung für ihre Tochter
entgegenzunehmen dennoch hat sich in
tearan etwas verändert verändert
berichtet unser Korrespondent GEG
Brase R v pur war dabei nach dem
todmasser aminis vor über einem Jahr
demonstrierte auch sie gegen
Kopftuchpflicht und für mehr
Bürgerrechte auch wenn es heute wieder
ruhig sei im Land hätten die Proteste
Wirkung erzielt sagt
sie die Leute denken heute völlig anders
über die Kopftuchpflicht viele Frauen
die Kopftuch tragen denken dass es nicht
richtig ist und selbst die Frauen die
das Kopftuch aus Überzeugung
me es sollte nicht verplicht
sein es waren Irans Frauen die die
Proteste trugen das habe sie
selbstbewusster gemacht sagt Roja sie
waren wütend die 22-Jährige Massa Amini
soll ihr Kopftuch nicht ordentlich
getragen haben deshalb war sie im
September vergangenen Jahres von der
moralpolizei festgenommen und vermutlich
tödlich verletzt worden die Unruhen
scheinen heute weit weg auf den Straßen
teerans und doch hat sich etw verändert
viele Frauen tragen kein Kopftuch mehr
und sie tun das zunehmend weniger
ängstlich als
früher heute habe ich mal ein Kopftuch
angezogen aber das passiert nur noch
selten ich bin aufnüpfiger geworden und
ziehe meist kein Kopftuch anszt da wo es
vorgeschrieben ist es sei denn ich werde
von den Behörden
gewahnt das islamisch konservative
Regime kämpft um dieses Symbol seiner
macht das iranische Parlament beschloss
vor kurzem erst ein härteres Kopftuch
gesetzt und versucht neuen Protest zu
unterdrücken als die Familie Masse
aminis zur Preisverleihung nach
Straßburg reisen wollte wurden ihre
Pässe eingezogen das Regime wollte der
Familie keine Bühne geben doch ob diese
Bühne den Frauen in Iran tatsächlich
hilft daran zweifeln viele von
ihnen das ist eine gute Aktion aber
leider helfen die Europäer dem
iranischen Volk nicht wirklich und das
sehen wir hier alle so
nicht ganz Roja fatach pur freut sich
dass ihre Stimmen im Ausland gehört
werden ir iranische Frauen haben die
Welt beeinflusst und haben die
Aufmerksamkeit auf sich gezogen und
diese Aufmerksamkeit bestärkt wiederum
die iranischen Frauen das gibt Ihnen das
Gefühl dass sie wichtig
sinder F sagt wir lassen uns nicht mehr
vorschreiben wie wir uns anziehen sollen
und immer weniger auf den Straßen stören
sich
daran und hier geht's weiter mit Heinz
Wolf und den Nachrichten noch mal
zunächst aus der Wirtschaft und während
auf der Weltklimakonferenz in Dubai über
die Energiefragen der Zukunft beraten
wird wie es mit fossiler Energie und
grünne Energie weitergeht lohnt auch der
Blick an die Kapitalmärkte Frank betmann
wo platzieren die Investoren das Geld ja
die Kapitalmärkte erleben gerade ihre
ganz eigene Energiewende viele Anleger
sind enttäuscht von den Windkraft Solar
und turbinenbauern es zeigt sich nämlich
dass deren häufig noch sehr junges
Geschäft extrem schwankungsanfällig ist
mit den steigenden Zinsen mussten
beispielsweise Betreiber von Offshore
Windparks zahlreiche Projekte streichen
Windräder auf hoheree das entwickelte
sich zuletzt häufiger zu einem
Minusgeschäft für Unternehmen und
Anleger dem Gegenüber verdienen die
Ölmultis derzeit gutes Geld ihre
Gewinnmargen nicht selten doppelt so
hoch wie im Erneuerbaren Sekt
kurz um viele Investoren entscheiden
sich gegenwärtig für die besseren
Renditeaussichten und so zogen Anleger
in Europa zuletzt über eine Milliarde
Euro aus den Grünen Fonds ab im Gegenzug
verzeichneten Fonds aus dem Öl und
Gasbereich Mittelzuflüsse von knapp 1,5
Milliarden Euro damit kein schiefes Bild
entsteht weltweit wird inzwischen mehr
in Erneuerbare als in fossile
Energieträger investiert die aktuelle
Gegenbewegung zeigt aber nicht nur auf
der Welt Klima Konferenz wird hart um
die klimaneutrale Zukunft gerungen auch
hier an den Kapitalmärkten Frank betmann
vielen
Dank im Prozess rund um die Corona
maskenaffäre in Bayern muss die
Angeklagte Andrea Tandler mit mindestens
4 Jahren und 3 Monaten haftrechnen alle
Verfahrensbeteiligten stimmten einem
verständigungsvorschlag des
landgerechtsmünchen 1 zu Andrea Tandler
Tochter eines früheren CSU
Generalsekretärs kassierte für die
Vermittlung von coronamasken Provisionen
in Höhe von fast 50 Millionen Euro
angeklagt wurde sie wegen
Steuerhinterziehung es gibt aktuelle
Unwetterwarnungen des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes gewarnt wird vor
ergebigem Dauerregen in
teilenbadenwürtenbergs und vor starkem
Tauwetter in Regionen
Bayerns in der türkischen fußballiga
sind im Moment alle Spiele auf
unbestimmte Zeit verschoben das hat der
Verband des Landes entschieden nach dem
alen Angriff auf einen Schiedsrichter
gegen mehrere mutmaßliche Beteiligte
wurden heute Haftbefehle
erlassen es ist das bestimmte Thema im
türkischen Fernsehen beim Spiel Ankara
gütsche gegen risisborwi Schiedsrichter
Halil um mer von einem Faustschlag
niedergestreckt auf dem Boden liegend
treten weitere Personen auf ihn ein
beteiligt an diesem brutalen Angriff
Ankas Präsident far kotscher sowie
weitere Betreuer des Vereins den die
Leistung des Schiedsrichters Missfallen
hatte der nationale Fußballverband
verurteilt die Geschehnisse auf
schärfste der türkische Fußball hat das
nicht verdient genug ist
genug Schiedsrichter meler kam mit einem
jochbeimbruch ins Krankenhaus ein
trauriger Höhepunkt im
Fußball das Jahr
2023 galoppiert auf sein Ende zu und um
mit dem Kanzler zu sprechen vieles davon
hätten wir nicht gebraucht aber es gab
auch meist unfreiwillig lustige Momente
wie unsere
frontalobersatiriker Werner de und
Andreas wimers festgestellt haben hier
kommen die Top se der besten
politikwitze dieses
Jahres
2023 geht zu Ende und die Stimmung die
Stimmung ist schon mal sagt die
Franziska KIF warum ja gute Frage
immerin hat sie eine Wahl verloren und
dann ist auch noch SPD Mitglied aber die
Stimmung ist schon mal weil jetzt werden
Preise verliehen und zwar die Preise für
die sechs besten politwit des Jahres vol
Wissing ist ein sehr sehr guter
Verkehrsminister was witzig ist weil
wissings Verkehrssektor die Klimaziele
gerissen hat der Minister aber
Sofortprogramm konsequent verweigert
Platz 6 dafür denn Andreas schuer war
ein guter
Verkehrsminister das ist definitiv noch
lustiger Platz 4 aber sichert sich mit
beachtlicher Selbstironie erneut Olaf
Scholz alles gut der Kanzler macht das
ordentlich und das wird auch
funktionieren
heizungsgesetz Kindergrundsicherung
Klimaschutzgesetz Migrationsdebatte 60
Milliarden Loch das mal eine sportliche
Aussage womit wir bei Platz numero 3
wären und bei Fifa Boss Infantino
FIFA Robin Hood auf foball na sicher
doch und die Klara Geiwitz ist Bob der
Baumeister und Trump Weidel wildersban
leupen höcke und m sind die sieben
Zwerge
apropulismus jetzt ist der Punkt
erreicht wo endlich die schweigende
große Mehrheit dieses Landes sich die
Demokratie wieder zurückholen muss ob
das als stellvertretender
Ministerpräsident so eine gute Idee ist
wissen wir nicht aber es reicht schon
für einen soliden zweiten Platz aber
Platz 1 geht auch 2023 wieder an den
guten alten
Slapstick entschuldigung das könnte ich
immer wiederhen
Entschuldigung ja gut jetzt s mal gut ne
also das tut auch weh ja einmal das und
zweitens beginnt ja auch bald schon
2024 wir werden als CSU dem nicht
zustimmen
witzig die Langfassung des satirischen
Jahresrückblicks können Sie jetzt schon
in der ZDF Mediathek ansehen oder am
Freitagabend um 23:30 Uhr hier im guten
alten Fernsehen und an diesem Abend um
0:20 Uhr gibt's dann unser heute schon
Update mit nasand göt mir Ihnen einen
schönen Abend und tschüss bis morgen
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend mitten im Advent lohnt sich
ein Blick in den Himmel denn in dieser
Woche können wir den wohl schönsten
sternschnuppenreen des Jahres beobachten
die
geminiden dahinter steckt vermutlich der
Asteroid pheton der hinterlässt im All
auf seiner Umlaufbahn eine kosmische
teilchenwolke die unser Planet dann
immer im Dezember durchfliegt viele der
Teilchen dringen in die Erdatmosphäre
ein verglühen dabei und wir können uns
über Sternschnuppen freuen manche einer
wünscht sich vielleicht sogar etwas und
weil das von der Erde ausgesehen in der
Nähe des Sternbilds Zwillinge lateinisch
Gemini passiert heißen diese
sternstuppen
geminiden leider ist die Chance auf
einen Anblick heute Nacht nicht
besonders groß denn es gibt viele
Regenwolken vor allem regnet es wieder
im Süden und auch im Nordwesten dazu
frischt der Wind auf im Norden aus
östlichen Richtungen sonst aus Südwest
und diese unterschiedlichen
Windrichtungen erklären die
unterschiedlichen Temperaturen es ist im
Nordosten nämlich Kühler heute Nacht 1
bis 3° sonst erreichen wir 4 bis 9°.
morgen spüren wir diesen Unterschied
meist erreichen die Temperaturen 6 bis
10° im Nordosten aber nur 2 bis 5° und
an dieser schwachen Luftmassengrenze
gibt's ein lang anhaltendes Regenband
der kühlere Ostwind mcht hier auch mal
Schnee unter ansonsten stellt sich
Schauerwetter ein dann fällt auch ganz
im Süden nicht mehr so viel Regen und
die dauerregenlage und auch die
tauwetterlage entspannt sich ab dem
Mittag etwas der Donnerstag und der
Freitag werden dann die kühlsten Tage
dieser Woche
tschüss